a primeira vez que eu vi um coração na
bancada do laboratório de anatomia da
faculdade eu fiquei absolutamente
impressionada
o coração é um músculo robusto capaz de
bater dois bilhões e meio de vezes ao
longo da vida de uma pessoa
desde o começo da faculdade uma das
primeiras coisas que a gente aprende
aqui um coração normal ele bate de 60 a
100 vezes por minuto e que qualquer
alteração nisso é sinal de que alguma
coisa está errada
o coração que bate mais rápido por
exemplo pode ser decorrência de um
sangramento de uma infecção ou até mesmo
da gente está abrindo até que são paulo
felizmente hoje a gente tem várias
formas de investigar um coração que bate
diferente do normal só que a medicina
persiste ainda com um problema e esse
problema é o fato da gente tratar as
pessoas de acordo com o que funciona
para a maioria delas não de acordo com
aquilo que funciona para cada uma com o
que seria ideal para cada um
só que raramente a gente pensa no que
que essa maioria eu vou explicar mais ou
menos o que é essa maioria agente médico
quando vai tratar um paciente a gente se
baseia em uma série de critérios
chamados de medicina baseada em
evidência
são eles que mostram pra gente por
exemplo quais são os estudos científicos
que mais tem peso para definir o que
funciona para a maioria
só que raramente a gente se pergunta o
que é que essa maioria né
eu fui atrás disso eu descobri um estudo
do wef de eike a agência que regula a
liberação de medicamentos novos nos
estados unidos que mostrava um perfil de
todos os participantes de todos os
pacientes que participaram de estudos
para liberar novas drogas no mundo
eu achei dois problemas nele um é que só
um
em toda a população participa desses
estudos e o segundo é que o que a gente
chama de maioria
na verdade corresponde a homens brancos
relativamente jovens com menos 50 e 65
anos e americanos
ou seja o que a gente chama de maioria
não reflete a diversidade da nossa
população
a gente está aqui em 2018 falando no
texas do futuro da saúde
só que a medicina ainda mais primitiva
do que a gente gosta de admitir a gente
fala tanto em medicina de precisão
mas o que a gente faz hoje em dia é
medicina de imprecisão
ok eu vim trazer algumas verdades para
vocês mas eu não tenho só notícias ruins
como casal falou eu sou médico
intensivista pra quem não sabe o
intensivismo médico da uti aquele médico
especializado em doentes graves ou que
têm grandes chances de se tornar grave
assim tem gente que escolhe si própria
vida
mas além disso eu sou uma pessoa
absolutamente apaixonada pela união
entre tecnologia e saúde e eu acredito
que isso tem o potencial para ajudar
tanto médicos como pacientes a entregar
uma saúde melhor para as pessoas e como
que isso acontece eu vou explicar para
vocês mas para explicar isso a gente
precisa entender o que está acontecendo
no mundo atualmente a gente vive um
momento único na história da humanidade
porque porque com os dispositivos desse
digitais que a gente tem os computadores
os tablets e smartphones
os relógios inteligentes e com as redes
sociais
a gente nunca gerou tanta informação no
mundo pra vocês terem uma idéia 90% de
toda a informação que existe hoje no
mundo de todos os dados que existem
foram criados nos últimos dois anos em
saúde e se ainda mais pronunciado a
gente vive uma era que querendo ou não a
gente nunca está offline a gente está
gerando dados o tempo inteiro pra vocês
conseguirem imaginar a magnitude disso
uma pessoa saudável ao longo da vida
dela se a gente juntar toda a informação
de saúde que ela gera esse é o
equivalente a 300 milhões
mães de livros cheios de conteúdo em
saúde
se a gente pega toda essa informação e
coloca dentro de tablets e empilha esses
tablets
a pilha que a gente consegue ela tem um
tamanho que é um terço da distância da
terra até a lua
só que isso é quanto a gente consegue
analisar de toda essa informação hoje em
dia com as ferramentas que a gente
possui é meio por cento
agora imagino tanto de informação que a
gente não tá podendo nesses 99 6 por
cento que a gente está deixando de lado
são informações absolutamente válidas
que poderiam mostrar pra gente por
exemplo como melhorar a qualidade de
vida das pessoas reduzir mortes
evitáveis prevê epidemias e por que não
até curar doenças
só que aqui a gente chega no segundo
desafio quem que vai analisar essa
quantidade de dados todas é o médico
na verdade a gente já vive um tsunami de
informação só para se manter atualizado
tem estudos que mostram que para um
especialista médico se mantém em dia com
absolutamente tudo que é publicado de
estudo científico na área dele seria
necessário estudar 167 horas por semana
isso é mais que 20 horas por dia é
impraticável
na verdade o nosso cérebro mesmo já não
é máquina suficiente para processar essa
quantidade de informação toda e muito
menos os sistemas de computação
tradicional porque porque eles fazem só
aquilo que eles foram programados para
fazer isso não trazem novidades
juntassem hipóteses que ajuda a gente a
resolver problemas
a gente pensa que poderia resolver esse
problema
a primeira coisa que vem à mente são
robôs dotados de inteligência artificial
mas a segunda coisa que vem em mente é
isso aqui são robôs dizimando populações
inteiras que foram inocentes o
suficiente pra confiar bétis e como que
o médico trabalha com inteligência
artificial se tornando um robô
infelizmente não felizmente isso tudo
está limitado às telas do cinema e os
livros de ficção científica
a inteligência artificial e os robôs
eles nunca vão substituir um médico
muito menos dizimar a humanidade
na verdade a gente precisa parar um
pouco de ter medo da inteligência
artificial entender melhor o que ela é
a inteligência artificial nada mais é
que uma série de ferramentas que
permitem que a nossa inteligência seja
aumentada
ela é terceira era da computação é a era
que vai permitir que a gente saia
daqueles sistemas que fazem só aquilo
que eles foram programados para fazer e
começa a receber esse mundo todo de
informação organizar toda essa
informação ver o que tem lá no meio
interagir com a gente de uma forma mais
natural e trazer hipóteses para a gente
resolver problemas ficando mais
inteligentes cada vez que a gente usa
eles em saúde isso tem um potencial
gigante porque isso pode ajudar a gente
a reduzir burocracia fazer diagnósticos
mais precisos e tratamentos que têm mais
chance realmente de ajudar as pessoas e
foi um pouco disso que me motivou
se até 2015 eu trabalhava de 80 senhoras
em três hotéis de diferentes hospitais
aqui de são paulo
hoje em dia eu divido meu tempo fazendo
isso mas também trabalhando numa grande
empresa de tecnologia desenvolvendo
projetos que ajudem a gente explorar
como inteligência artificial pode ajudar
médicos e pacientes a entregar uma saúde
melhor para as pessoas e eu vou dar
alguns exemplos do que já é possível pra
vocês eu começo pela oncologia
especialidade que trata o câncer
a oncologia uma das especialidades em
que é mais difícil se manter atualizado
cerca de 75 mil artigos são publicados
por ano que o oncologista tem que saber
com medicações novas novos regimes de
tratamento
hoje em dia já é possível que médicos
oncologistas no momento da consulta
cruzem os dados do paciente dele com
toda a literatura científica disponível
e isso traga de forma ranqueada os
tratamentos que têm mais chance de dar
certo para cada um desses pacientes ao
invés do que funciona para a maioria das
pessoas isso tem sido utilizado desde
hospitais de ponta nos estados unidos
até em países como a índia
a índia tem milton com lojistas para uma
população de 1.4 milhões de pacientes
muitos desses pacientes autodiagnósticos
nem tinham a chance de conseguir chegar
num centro de tratamento de oncologia
muito bem infelizmente acaba morrendo
antes disso
então o que é inteligência artificial
tem feito é permitido que médicos mais
generalista consigam adiantar esse
processo e começar o tratamento desses
pacientes para que eles têm uma
esperança e consigam ter o tempo
inclusive de chegar num o lojista que
vai dar continuidade ao tratamento deles
no sequenciamento genético já é possível
utilizar a inteligência artificial
também a gente consegue hoje em dia usar
esse tipo de ferramenta para ler por
exemplo o resultado do sequenciamento
genético de uma pessoa com câncer isso
detectar e ranquear as mutações mais
relevantes dessa pessoa cruzar com a
literatura e procurar os tratamentos
específicos para essa mutação aqui
também a gente sai do modelo atual que a
gente tem de tratar o câncer que é
tratar pelo tipo de órgão que acomete em
câncer de mama um câncer gástrico e um
câncer de próstata e passa a tratar o
que funciona para o câncer daquela
pessoa para a mutação daquela pessoa
humanos conseguem fazer essa análise
também mas para analisar o
sequenciamento genético de uma pessoa
são necessárias cerca de 160 horas e
quase uma semana com inteligência
artificial esse tempo cai para 10
minutos
o primeiro caso de sucesso de uso da
inteligência artificial para o
sequenciamento genético aconteceu no
japão no hospital da universidade de
tóquio existe uma paciente com leucemia
que já tinha passado por três regimes de
tratamento sem sucesso porque eram os
que funcionava para a maioria
só que ela não era maioria daí os
médicos de lá resolveram testar
vamos colocar o dado do sequenciamento
dessa paciente para a inteligência
artificial ler e analisar junto com a
gente
eles chegaram a descobrir que ela tinha
uma mutação rara para a qual existe um
tratamento que não tinha sido tentado
ainda hoje em dia essa paciente está se
recuperando
outro exemplo é o diabetes
milhares de pacientes com diabetes eles
doaram os dados dos medidores de glicose
e de açúcar do sangue deles pra serem
interpretados por meio de uma solução de
inteligência artificial isso permitiu
chegar num algoritmo que prevê com três
horas de antecedência
quando essa pessoa vai ter hipoglicemia
hipoglicemia queda de açúcar no sangue
que é super perigosa para os pacientes
com diabetes ea partir do momento que o
sistema detecta isso ele mesmo já
dispara mensagens smartphone da pessoa
avisando que isso vai acontecer com
medidas que ela pode tomar para evitar
que isso aconteça
bom os exemplos que eu posso dar pra
vocês são várias do que está acontecendo
hoje em dia só que os pacientes
eu vocês todos nós a gente tem uma
oportunidade única neste momento que a
gente tem esse poder computacional nos
nossos bolsos
por meio dos celulares dos smartphones
nesse momento a gente tem a oportunidade
de começar a ser mais ativo em relação à
nossa saúde
isso pode começar de várias formas desde
a gente exigindo ter acesso ao nosso
prontuário nos médicos e instituições
que a gente passa porque é pra que a
gente também seja dono desses dados e
não só eles até transformar os
aplicativos que ensinam mais sobre a
nossa saúde em nossas aliadas que a
gente entender quantos passos a gente
dar como a gente dorme o que a gente
escolhe comer e como isso impacta na
nossa saúde
a idéia aqui é que a partir do momento
que a gente é dono dos nossos dados
a gente pode decidir o que fazer com
eles é mais ou menos o que a gente faz
no ese em que a gente compartilha os
dados do nosso trajecto em contrapartida
a gente recebe quanto tempo a gente vai
ter no trânsito quais obstáculos que a
gente vai ter um caminho como evitá los
e como tem um caminho melhor para a
gente se locomover se a gente faz isso
na saúde e compartilhando os nossos
dados
a gente começa a entender que tipo de
tratamentos e medidas funcionam para
cada pessoa em cada bairro em cada
cidade em cada país e no mundo na
verdade uma das coisas mais humanas que
existem quando a gente pensa é do órgão
uma pessoa sem necessidade eu acredito
no futuro em que a gente não vai só
drogas mas a gente vai ser possível doar
dados também porque está aí ao invés de
ajudar uma pessoa por vez
a gente consegue ajudar várias ea gente
consegue garantir que cada vez mais
corações consigam bater aqueles dois
bilhões e meio de vezes que eles
nasceram pra bater
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]